[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC JOHNSON: Hi, I'm Eric, an
engineering manager at Google,
working on open source
integrations for Google Cloud
Platform.
This is the first, in a
short series of videos,
talking about some of the great
open source tools by HashiCorp,
and how they can be used
with Google Cloud Platform.
[LASER BEAM]
Each video will focus
on a specific tool,
but will be part
of an overall demo
that we'll keep adding to with
each new video in the series.
And over Hangouts,
I have with me
today Arden [? Yakamenko, ?]
a Googler based
in Sydney, and Chris Roberts,
an engineer at HashiCorp
based in Portland, Oregon.
Thanks for joining
me today, fellows.
Here's the background
story for this series.
Each video will have a
different set of guest speakers.
But let's imagine they're
part of a small game studio
and are working on their next
project, a 1980s retro style
space game, but
updated the plan a web
with multi-player support.
It's been designed to have a
separate JavaScript front end
and back end server written in
the Go programming language.
Through the next
few videos, we'll
follow the project along
from the development phase
up through a demo
to the CEO, and then
finally the big launch.
But for today's
video, we're still
in the development
phase of the project
with a couple of
developers actively
working on writing the code.
So where do the HashiCorp
tools fit into this?
Today we'll start with Vagrant.
Chris, can you tell us a
little bit about Vagrant
and what problems it solves?
CHRIS ROBERTS: Sure.
Vagrant is a tool primarily
used by software developers.
It provides an easy
and repeatable way
to create custom
developer environments.
Vagrant has been
around for a long time
and brings together
the well known worlds
of VMs and operating
systems, along
with some of the
same patterns, you
may have heard
about with Docker,
but without having to adopt a
new container-centric world.
ERIC JOHNSON: Thanks, Chris.
I think we've all heard stories,
or experienced this ourselves,
of working at places
where developers create
their environments by
copying and pasting
a bunch of shell commands
from some internal wiki page.
Vagrant essentially replaces
those set up instructions
with a single
configuration file that
can be put under version
control and treated just
like your code.
Correct me if I'm
wrong, but a common use
case is for developers
to use Vagrant
to spin up local
VMs if they have
VirtualBox or VMware installed.
CHRIS ROBERTS: Yes,
that's correct.
With local VMs, the
developer isn't cluttering up
their host's operating system
with a bunch of extra software,
or having to run a
specific operating system.
It's easy to create and
destroy these VMs too.
What can start to
get tricky, though,
is when developers want to
collaborate using a local VM.
And while Vagrant does
have a share feature,
that may not always
be a viable option.
SPEAKER 3: So, they can use a
remote VM that they can share.
This is where GCP integration
with Vagrant comes in.
Google Cloud Platform has
many different services
ranging from big data
and machine learning,
all the way down to
infrastructure offerings
such as our VM service,
Compute Engine.
Let's get started with how
developers can use Vagrant
to spin up a shared GCP VM.
CHRIS ROBERTS: First, go to
vagrantup.com and download
the version for
your local system.
SPEAKER 3: Next, go to
cloud.google.com/free-trial
to create a Google
Cloud Platform account,
if you don't already have one.
Next, you'll need to enable
the Google Compute Engine API.
A service account and a
corresponding JSON credential
file will need to
be created as well.
Now we'll spin up a
Google Compute Engine
instance with my
hyperspace video game
and develop and environment.
Ready to go.
Don't forget to install the
Vagrant Google driver using
Vagrant's plug in command.
I'll do that with a
Vagrant up-command
with Google providers specified.
Of course, for Vista work,
I'll need to create my Vagrant
file first.
Chris, can you walk us
through our Vagrant file?
CHRIS ROBERTS: Sure.
First, we define the
provider information
to access the GCE API.
This includes a project
ID, client email,
and user information.
Next, we provide details
for the type of instance
we want Vagrant to
create and set the SSH
information to allow access.
Using Vagrant sync
folders, we're
able to push the local source
code to the new instance.
And finally, a
provisioning script
is used to create
the new instance.
Here, a simple shell provisioner
runs an in-line script
on the remote instance.
Vagrant also supports
other provisioners,
like Chef and Puppet, for more
complex instance configuration.
Now let's see how the GCE
instance is coming along.
SPEAKER 3: Okay, now that
the Vagrant-up has finished,
you can see in the console that
I have a new GCE VM running.
When I click on its
public IP address,
you can see that the
game is up and working.
Vagrant and GCE make a
great combination for us
in areas like this, when
you have multiple developers
needing access to the same VM.
GCE will store users'
SSH keys and metadata,
and those keys are propagated to
the VM to allow remote access.
CHRIS ROBERTS: Yes, with
a quick Vagrant SSH,
you can see there are
multiple users in the home
directory, each with their
own SSH key to access the VM.
You can also see that Arden's
source code was copied
at the VM, and [? serve ?]
hyperspace directory,
as was specified in
his Vagrant file.
So that was pretty quick--
almost as fast as
spinning up a local VM.
ERIC JOHNSON: Yeah,
that looked really easy.
Now for those looking to get
started for their first time,
where is the best place
for them to learn more?
CHRIS ROBERTS: Sure.
To get started with
Vagrant or to learn more,
check out vagrantup.com.
ERIC JOHNSON:
Thanks for watching.
Check out our last video
in the series playlist
and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel.